-We're here with
Dr. Anthony Fauci.
You were played over the las
12 months by Brad Pitt on "SNL,"
by Kate McKinnon on "SNL."
I had forgot -- I was
even in this sketch in 200
during the anthrax scare.
You were played by Chris Kattan.
Let's take a quick look.
-What about the post offices
-We've given each post offic
some baby wipes
and a DustBuster.
[ Laughter ]
-But what about the contaminated
buildings in New York?
Are they safe?
-I don't know, lady!
[ Laughter ]
I haven't been in New York
in weeks.
You think I'm crazy?
[ Laughter ]
-Now, Dr. Fauci, I guess
it probably is never good
for the rest of us
when you are being portrayed
on "Saturday Night Live."
Is that safe?
-That is true.
When I'm on
"Saturday Night Live,"
it's not good news for
the health of the country.
-I love Chris Kattan a great
deal, but I would imagine,
insofar as the people
who played you,
Brad Pitt was probably
the highlight.
-Yeah. Well, he definitely was
He did a really good job, bu
McKinnon was also spectacular.
I mean, she's really amazing
I like them both, both of them
-You grew up in Brooklyn,
and your family owned
a pharmacy in Brooklyn.
Can you tell me a little bit
about how early did your parents
have you and your siblings
working in there?
-Well, you know, we used t
work behind the counter.
But my job was mostly delivering
prescriptions on my Schwinn bike
in the Bensonhurst section
of Brooklyn
with my little basket,
and the prescriptions in there
going from house to house,
delivering it,
getting a 25-cent
or 15-cent tip.
[ Laughter ]
-See, that's the problem
with overregulation.
These days they won't let
a 12-year-old bike around drugs.
[ Laughter ]
You know, I know your dad
went to Columbia University?
Is that right?
-Correct, yes.
-Do you think that
somehow led to your choice
to go into infectious diseases
-You know, I think it did
in the sense of not necessaril
infectious disease
but medicine in general.
You know, I had the concep
of service to people
who had a disadvantage
with regard to their health.
I was always struck by the fac
that what we were doing
was actually helping people.
I mean, at a much lower
level than,
obviously,
as a hospital physician.
I was just riding a bicycle, you
know, delivering prescriptions
But there was an element about
that, about helping people
that sort of stood with me
throughout my education.
-You know, I think we all have
or tend to have
sort of a short memory insofar
as what the American peopl
can overcome when
faced with a hurdle.
You lived through smallpox
and the vaccination of tha
living in New York
as a very young kid.
What do you remember
about what New York
managed to pull off
during that time?
-Well, that was
really extraordinary,
what they pulled off --
I believe it was 1947.
I was a child, and some ma
had gone to Mexico on a vacation
and then came back to New York
was infected with smallpox
And the city of New York
vaccinated like 6 million people
in a 2 1/2- to 3-week
period of time.
And one of them
was me and my family,
because the entire city of New
York got vaccinated that year.
And it prevented an outbreak
There were 12 cases, you know,
hospitalizations, 2 deaths
but we didn't have an outbreak
in the city.
It was really extraordinar
public health measure back then.
-You worked -- You've had
this job for seven presidents.
You know, I don't necessaril
want to rehash
the last four years,
but was it uniquely differen
having your job
during the last administration
than the previous five, I guess?
-Yeah.
It was, Seth, and it was
for a number of reasons,
because, I mean, you don't
need me to tell you
that we're really
living through a period
of extreme divisiveness
in our country.
And in order to address
and attack a deadly pandemic
everybody's got to
pull together.
And what we saw over the las
year was public health issue
that were taking on
a political connotation,
which really just doesn't work
You know, it just does not work.
Everybody's got to be
on the same page.
And when you have wearing a mask
or not wearing a mask
becomes a political statement,
that was not helpful at all.
And I think there's any lesson
that we learned from this
is that when we're fightin
a common enemy,
we've got to do it togethe
because we're all
in the same boat
and we can't be
pulling against each other
-Of course, you know,
the decisiveness --
I should say the divisiveness,
excuse me --
that is still as big a problem
as it was at
the start of this pandemic
And that leads me now
to this next question.
Do you feel as though
we are any better prepared
the next time this happens, be
it in 5 years or 10 years or 20?
-Well, if we essentially
acclimate ourselves
to the lessons learned
and we don't have
a short-lived corporate memory
we will do well.
We learned some serious lesson
about allowing
our local public health
infrastructure
to essentially become much
weaker than it was decades ago
We also realize
that we've got to be part of
the international community.
Withdrawing out of
the international scene --
The United States
is a global leader
and has been a global leader
in every major pandemic.
A global pandemic requires
a global response.
So we need to get back
into the action
and reassume our leadershi
globally.
-Last question --
COVID fatigue is real.
And I know you can't tell us
when we're going back to normal,
but give us one optimistic thing
to leave this interview with
-Yeah, the optimistic thing,
Seth,
is that this is definitely
going to end.
We need to hang in there
a bit longer.
The saving grace in all of this,
if there's one big success
story, is the vaccines.
If we get the overwhelming
majority of the population
vaccinated, we're going to hav
a very, very different situation
than we have now.
We're going to start to approach
normal, and we will get there.
-In a normal year, do people
ask you about allergies more
-[ Laughs ]
I haven't been asked about
an allergy in a long time.
[ Laughter ]
-'Cause, you know,
we were talking here
that it's almost allergy season,
and it feels really quaint now
But I bet two, three years ago
that was all anybody was
ever calling you about.
-Well, yeah, sort of.
You're right.
[ Laughter ]
Interests change
depending on the circumstances
-Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
Keep up the important work